13 heroes gave their lives i was just at
dover air force base for the dignified
transfer i am the repository of all good
humane compassionate feeling
that has been completely exploded over
the course of the last four weeks
last night
more than 24 hours after we found out
that the american military had left joe
biden decided to give a speech
joe biden
had basically been hiding in the
basement
because the fallout from this is bad
it's really bad it turns out that when
you leave hundreds of american citizens
behind
and then when you leave probably
thousands of american green card holders
behind and tens of thousands of siv
holders behind
and a myriad number of afghan allies who
worked with us and millions of people
who actually don't want to live under
the predations of the taliban it turns
out you don't look empathetic it turns
out you look like a piece of bleep
that's what it turns out you look like
and when you do so in absolutely
cowardly fashion refusing to answer
questions from the press giving
mushmouth statements every couple of
days lying
overtly throughout the entire process
talking about how everybody will get out
talking about how we're going to stay
long enough to get everybody out talking
about how every contingency here was
planned turns out people don't like you
it turns out they think that your
empathy is merely an act at that point
and they are right and you can see this
in joe biden's poll numbers which have
now sunk into the low 40s and after
being dead solid at 50 his entire
presidency he is now down to about 40 41
in a lot of these polls
and and falling fast because he is not
competent and he is not capable and he
is not the quote-unquote empathetic
grandfather figure that so many people
thought they were electing
that is the takeaway so joe biden goes
into hiding yesterday he doesn't come
out
he has his secretary of state tony
blinken give a full ridiculous speech in
which he looked like he was delivering a
hostage video he's looking slightly off
camera at his cue cards
he had the centcom commander kenneth
mckenzie go out there and humiliate
himself by saying a bunch of stuff like
the taliban are now our best friends and
we handle this beautifully
and finally joe biden emerges after
delaying his speech he was supposed to
give a speech yesterday about 1 30
eastern time and then it was about 2 45
eastern time he was supposed to speak
and then finally he came out after three
o'clock which is his normal way he isn't
uh he i don't know what's going on
behind the scenes over there but they
have not hit a time for him to like
they're much better about hitting
timelines in coordination with the
taliban than they are with actually
keeping their schedule with regard to
the press right they routinely call a
time when he's going to speak to the
press and then they just kind of blow
right through it so finally he emerges
and he proceeds to give a 30-minute
diatribe
and it really was a diatribe he is angry
he is he is grumpy
he's pissed off that you've questioned
his obviously wonderful strategy
he blames every single person by himself
he has done everything absolutely
perfectly this thin-skinned buffoon
everything he has done here was part of
the plan except when it wasn't part of
the plan and if it wasn't part of the
plan that's everybody else's fault but
his
joe biden has said repeatedly the buck
stops with him the american public are
holding him to that right now but he
doesn't want to be held to that he's
lying he wants the buck to stop with
trump he wants the buck to stop with the
afghan military he wants this buck to
stop with his own military commanders
he is hiding behind everybody for the
for the one decision that he made and
only he made which was pull out right
now damn the consequences okay everybody
else is to blame everybody the people
who are stuck in afghanistan are to
blame
they're the ones they should have just
gotten out earlier obviously
the president of the united states is a
pathetic spectacle
at this point in time and once again
the the key to all of this is
understanding that it has utterly
undercut his image of himself and his
image on the world stage not because
everyone thought he was an expert not
because everybody thought that he was
fluent in foreign policy that was a
creation of the press it was always a
myth joe biden was never fluent at
anything
the man's terrible at everything he
hasn't made a good foreign policy
decision his entire career
and he's he's so bad on foreign policy
he opposed the bin laden raid now of
course he uses the bin laden raid as an
excuse to get out of afghanistan but he
opposed it at the time
he's no one was under the if you had
watched joe biden his entire career no
one was under the impression that this
guy was any sort of einstein
i mean the guy wasn't even a sixth grade
science student
joe biden has always been horrific
in terms of policy
okay but
the one thing that was said for him and
this was again his entire pitch against
donald trump his entire pitch it was not
my policy is going to be better than
trump because his policies were not
gonna be better than trump polls showed
americans actually liked trump's
policies better than bidens his entire
pitch throughout 2020 is i am a nice
person i am an empathetic person i am a
person who cares donald trump the
cruelty is the point is adam sort of
famously said the cruelty is the point
with trump but i joe biden i am the
repository of all good humane
compassionate feeling
that has been completely exploded over
the course of the last four weeks he
ain't getting that back
the impression that joe biden is
somebody who cares deeply about america
about american citizens that this is
somebody who you know how many times
over the course of his campaign
he tweeted that he's going to build a
society where we leave no one behind and
now he is physically leaving behind
americans with the worst people on earth
the taliban
and actually i should say like the
second or third worst people on earth
because actually the taliban is not even
as bad as al qaeda or isis which the
taliban is currently hosting
right this is this is a guy who who
posed as he was going to unify america
around solidarity and instead he's been
divisive and said he has been awful and
again his compassion only extends as far
as the front of his face that is it
it extends as far as a mirror
joe biden is compassionate to one person
and one person only joe biden which is
why when he speaks about grief he
doesn't speak about anybody else's grief
he speaks about his own personal
experiences of suffering and grief
he did it again in his speech last night
so
yeah take that for what you will
but if a politician has one pitch and a
pitch incompetence
and the pitch is not coherent the pitch
is i'm a nice person and then that falls
apart you have to ask yourself what
exactly is his pitch for staying
president at this point
what is the pitch and the answer is
there is no pitch
he proved that last night
in extremis it's it's
pretty amazing so as i've mentioned
before when it comes to politicians i
don't think you should look to them for
empathy i don't think policy should be
rooted in empathy i think it should be
rooted in what is the most practical
what is the most practical and what is
most in america's interest
but joe biden doesn't believe that joe
biden believes that policy should be
rude in empathy so if he is
unempathetic
he has nothing else to back his policy
because his policy is obviously not
pragmatic his policy is obviously not
effective it is not useful and so he is
left spinning in circles and that's what
we saw last night so the president
toddles out to the microphone
and he proceeds to declare that what he
has done is triumphant he's triumphant
about all of this
and we've been giving you the updates
i mean we gave tens of billions of
dollars in american military equipment
to the taliban we've got thousands of
americans and american green card
holders who are stranded behind enemy
lines we have china and russia on the
move
uh quick note yesterday the taliban were
not apparently hanging somebody from a
helicopter is just somebody taking a
joyride beneath the helicopter wait for
a couple of weeks for them to actually
hang people beneath the helicopters in
any case here was joe biden yesterday
beginning with a triumphal announcement
of what he joe biden had done
last night in kabul
the united states ended
20 years of war in afghanistan
the longest war in american history
we completed one of the biggest airlifts
in history
with more than 120 000 people evacuated
to safety
that number is more than double
what most experts thought were possible
no nation
no nation has ever done anything like it
in all of history
that's how good this was it was a
historic win for the united states to
turn over the country back to the people
who committed 911 or provided cover for
those people it's a historic win
you know how many people we evacuated
from the titanic here man we are good at
evacuating people from the titanic what
a plan what a masterfully conceived plan
well what about you might be asking
yourself what about the 13 dead service
people because you decided to hand
security over to the taliban joe biden
has an answer for you
they did it
facing a crush of enormous crowds
seeking to leave the country
and they did it
knowing isis-k terrorists sworn enemies
of the taliban
were lurking in the midst of those
crowds 20 service members were wounded
in the service of this mission
13 heroes gave their lives
i was just at dover air force base
for the dignified transfer
yeah checking your watch every five
seconds and insulting the military
parents by the way does he ever mention
here why it was that uh they were facing
a crush of enormous crowd seeking to
leave the country
and why they had to face down isis k
terrace at no point does he actually
mention this the reason this happened is
because he gave up bagram air base which
exists outside of kabul the reason that
this happened is because he decided to
hand over local security directly to the
taliban the washington post has reported
instead of taking the taliban's own
offer of allowing the united states to
maintain control of kabul at least long
enough to evacuate our people
at no point is he going to take the
blame for that even though this is again
a complete biden policy see everything
was masterfully handed handled
and the military's challenges well those
were those were natural those those were
just how things were going to be okay
then he starts the blame game
so remember captain compassion over here
he uh the the blame game is so normally
if you're compassionate you normally say
you take the hit you move on not joe
biden this is everybody's fault but his
so he starts by ripping into the the
collapse of the afghan government and
lying about it he says that he was uh
that he had contingency plans for the
collapse of that and it was it was sort
of foreseen that's we know that's a lie
in july he was explicitly telling people
it would not be like the fall of saigon
that the taliban did not have the
ability to take over the entire country
quickly he himself said that by the way
he was lying at the time he was lying at
the time there's another story from the
daily mail today july 23rd
that
that biden actually called
the now departed afghan president ashraf
ghani
and he saw that the taliban had been
making gains and he asked gani to lie
about it
he asked gani to say to everybody that
everything is going fine apparently
it's not a great phone call guys i've
noticed that impeachment happens over
phone calls these days that's not a
great phone call biden apparently
said to gani he that he wanted
ghani to lie to people he said quote i
need not tell you the perception around
the world and in parts of afghanistan is
things are not going well in terms of
the fight against the taliban there is a
need whether it is true or not there is
a need to project a different picture
okay so he knew things were going badly
and he told gani to lie about it here
was joe biden explaining however that
you know we had an assumption about the
afghan military holding it turned out
not to be accurate no one could have
predicted this but we had contingency
plans number one a lot of people did
predict it number two he knew what was
going on and number three he did not
have a good contingency plan
that assumption
that the afghan government would be able
to hold on
for a period of time beyond military
drawdown
turned out not to be accurate
but
i still instructed our national security
team to prepare for every eventuality
even that one
and that's what we did
they did they prepared for every
eventuality so many eventually well now
who are you going to believe joe biden
or your own eyes
clearly they did not prepare for these
eventualities
and clearly he was putting artificial
constraints on his own military i mean
mark milley said as much he said we were
told that we could have six to seven
hundred troops if by the way their
contingency plans have been so excellent
why did we have to re-insert thousands
of troops on the ground in order to
effectuate this evacuation
and if there was such a great
contingency why are there still
literally tens of thousands of people
who made promises who still stuck there
so uh so he continues along these lines
we made contingency plans this was so
incoherent on the one hand it's the
afghan military's fault on the other
hand we made contingency plans on the
one hand it's trump's fault on the other
hand i deserve all the credit like he
was all over the place because when you
don't have an actual defense you just
have to throw at the wall and that's
what joe biden is doing right here
so he continues along these lines
so we were ready
when the afghan security forces after
two decades of fighting for their
country
and losing thousands of their own
did not hold on as long as anyone
expected
we're ready when they
and the people of afghanistan watch
their own government collapse
and the president flee
amid the corruption of malfeasance
handing over the country to their enemy
the taliban
and significantly increasing the risk to
u.s personnel
and our
allies okay so again everybody's to
blame it was all part of the plan but
the afghan military completely collapsed
and that's because they're corrupt and
terrible
so i just have a question for joe biden
at any point here are you gonna mention
the fact that you completely withdrew
close air support as well as all
american military contractors from
afghanistan and destroyed the military
from the within and announced that we
were going to leave
at any point no of course not
okay but don't worry according to joe
biden there was not only a plan to deal
with the complete collapse of the
country there was an extr an excellent
plan for the evacuation which doesn't
explain why we have all these people
still stuck on the ground over there and
no personnel but according to joe biden
all part of the plan and you have to be
a to believe him you really do you
have to be a com a clinically stupid
person in order to believe this stuff
here's joe biden talking about the
wonders of his plan
as a result
to safely extract american citizens
before august 31st
as well as embassy personnel
allies and partners
and those afghans who had worked with us
and fought alongside of us for 20 years
i had authorized 6 000
troops american troops to kabul
to help secure the airport
as general mckenzie said
this is the way the mission was designed
it was designed to operate under severe
stress and attack
and that's what it
did okay so if you designed the mission
then who's to blame for leaving the
taliban in control of security and
getting 13 american service members
killed
but it's either your plan or it ain't
your plan which is it
okay but then this also leaves a
question if this was such a
well-designed and brilliant plan why are
there so many people left behind enemy
lines right a normal plan you said you
were going to take care of every
contingency a normal plan would have you
know dealt with the fact that we now
have at least hundreds of american
citizens behind enemy lines and an
unspecified number of green card holders
by the way remember how at the very
beginning of this they were saying there
were 10 to 15 000 americans in kabul
remember how that shrunk all the way
down to 6 000. you wonder how that
happened it's because they started
excising anybody who's a green card
holder if you're an american green card
holder you no longer count
you were somebody with legal papers you
no longer counted so they just redefined
who got to count as an american for
purposes of getting them out even though
green card holders have the same rights
from the us embassy as american citizens
proper
that's how they played the statistical
game anyway you might be wondering if it
was such a great plan designed by this
brilliant
piece of of human genius
then why are so many people left behind
joe biden has an answer
the collapse of the country was the
afghan military's fault not his he had a
plan
and the evacuation if it was
unsuccessful with regard to these people
that is their fault that three-year-old
we talked about earlier that
three-year-old we told them over and
over you need to come to the airport and
the three-year-old just kept crying and
watching elmo nothing we can do about
that here's joe biden blaming the people
who got left behind
since march
we reached out 19 times to america
in afghanistan
with multiple warnings
and offers to help them leave
afghanistan all the way back as far as
march
after we started the evacuation 17 days
ago
we did initial outreach and analysis
and identified around 5 000 americans
who had decided earlier to stay in
afghanistan
but now
wanted to leave
our operation allied rescue
ended up getting more than 5
500 americans out
um okay so here he says well you know in
march we were telling people to leave
yeah and in july you were saying the
country definitely was not gonna fall so
which is it dude
okay so then he gets to the people who
are still left and he says you know what
their fault
they wanted to stay probably all these
people trying to get out probably their
fault
everybody's fault except for this
daughtering fool
now we believe that about 100 to 200
americans remain in afghanistan
with some intention
to leave
most of those who remain
are dual citizens
long-time residents
but earlier decided to stay
because of their family roots in
afghanistan
the bottom line
of americans in afghanistan who wanted
to leave were able to leave
and for those remaining americans
there is no deadline
we remain committed to get them out if
they want to come out
if they want to come out but they don't
want to come out right it's their fault
they're stuck there obviously i mean
that's clearly what's happening right
there by the way i do love when he uses
stats like 90 of americans we got them
out now they're saying it's 98 of
americans right they're trying to
downgrade the number of americans who
are actually stuck there even though
they still don't have exact numbers
90 of americans well you know it's
unbelievable here's here's an
unbelievable stat for you you ready on 9
11 99.99
nine i believe 99.999 percent of
americans were not killed by terrorists
on 9 11. isn't that amazing wow what an
amazing success story that was
incredible
like truly
inspiring
the president of the united states here
okay in a second we'll get to him
continuing to make excuses uh him
continuing with his false binaries and
his straw men
this is a pathetic spectacle for the
united states he's completely destroyed
american interests in the near east and
in in central asia and um he has done so
while destroying his own reputation by
the way whatever was left of that
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe